hey what's up guys it's mkbhd and it's
that time of the year again it's the end
of the summer which means if you're a
student like me back-to-school time
actually this means that this is one of
the last videos actually it's the last
video you will be seeing in this sort of
place so the very next video you see
will be in my new apartment so thumbs up
if you're ready for that this summer so
definitely get a speeding ticket and
went really really fast but this is a
video about the top three gadgets that
were actually released during this
summer which would include maybe May 2
now the end of August so four months of
a solid run for technology in 2012 let's
take a look at what made the list just
FYI this is a video response to a very
similar video from mr. Tai Box 1-2-3 the
annotation to his videos right up there
if you want to check out his top three
gadgets but let's go ahead and get right
started with this one number three on my
list is the retina MacBook Pro released
by Apple and somewhere at WWDC along
with a bunch of other things and I think
that was the most impressive
technologically and in terms of hardware
that came out of Apple's entire event
now I'm mkbhd so if you didn't already
know the HD stands for high definition
which basically means I like a lot of
pixels as a matter of fact one of the
top reasons that I would recommend the
iPad 3 to anyone is the number of pixels
on that display the Retina display is
one of the best things Apple has going
for it and moving that up to the retina
MacBook Pro line of 15-inch 28 80 by
1440 display was really impressive to
someone like me now I don't own a retina
MacBook Pro I have used one I've seen
one in more than one occasion and using
in person is really impressive I like
the fact that text is so sharp that
images are really crisp and that more
and more apps and content are able to
take advantage of that display now I'm
hoping that someday they'll be on the
desktops and maybe not just phones and
iPods but moving up to tablets then to
laptops the next logical step is
desktops and then some you know crazy 8k
TVs later but the main point is I love
the fact that it's moving upwards in the
line I don't have one because I have a
desktop and a tablet and a phone so it
doesn't really fit in but I would
definitely love to see this technology
moving upwards number two on my list is
the Samsung Galaxy s3 which launched in
the United States this summer and I
happen to have a Verizon version right
here now this takes the cake and gets a
list
for the HTC One X for me because of the
simultaneous multiple carrier launch
there is an identical on the outside
of this phone for Verizon AT&T Sprint
and t-mobile all at the same time which
means if you buy an accessory meant for
the samsung galaxy of three no matter
what carrier you want if you want to get
say a custom black back like I have on
mine you can buy it and it will work on
your Galaxy s3 whether you have the
international version the LTE version
the Verizon version the ATT whatever you
might have it'll work and that's really
impressive not only that but it's a
great phone in itself I happen to be
running this as my daily driver it's got
signage is my ten nightly on it so it's
running Android 4.1 jelly bean so
project buttery goodness haven't done a
review of that yet but if you want to
see my review on the galaxy s3 phone
Bamm it's right there I love the device
and I can't say much bad about it so
check it out if you're in the market for
a phone and last but not least the
number one gadget released during the
summer of 2012 you probably already saw
this coming it's the Nexus 7 tablet from
Google now this makes a list over the
other Asus Transformer is particularly
the Infinity which is the most recent to
come out during the summer because it is
a Nexus device this is a device that
will get updates straight from Google as
soon as they're available Asus has been
pretty good about getting jellybean on
to the current transformers so for
example the TF 300 has already gotten
jellybean but when the next version of
Android comes out and we don't even know
when that's going to be I can guarantee
that the Nexus just like the Nexus phone
the Nexus 7 will also get that update
immediately the support is beyond
awesome from Google and I got to applaud
them you know pushing out updates so
fast I review the Nexus 7 already on my
channel and it's a great tablet right
out the box like we've said already on
Android 4.1 I have mine set up some
pretty fancy home screens going on right
here but it's a great tablet and it's a
great great value one-handed device it's
a new form factor it's a new product
market because it's the first 7-inch
true Android tablet so many good things
to say about this device the only thing
is there were some display issues so you
might get a faulty one maybe a one in a
million
or one in 10,000 chance but if you do
get one just return it and get a new one
and it's a great device well well worth
$200 for a nexus so what do you guys
think over the course of the summer
they've been some really impressive
things released but I can't throw all of
them on to my top three list some things
I left out like the Nintendo 3ds XL or
even some software like iOS 6 and
Android 4.1 they can't all be on the
list so go ahead and leave your number
one thing gadget tech related thing
announced during summer of 2012 and be
sure to give a thumbs up on the comments
that you like to get them seen and I'll
update the description below the like
button on this video so you guys can see
all the best things that have been
written by you guys in the comments
either way thanks for watching this
video and I'll talk to you guys in my
next one in my new setup background and
yes tourists coming maybe not the next
video but hopefully you guys I'll see
you in the next video in my new
apartment
base
[Music]
you
[Music]